hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the water lead podcast thanks for
tuning in to another episode and if you
have been enjoying this podcast please
do me a favor and go give it a five star
review on whatever platform you listen
to that will be greatly appreciated and
also as always I have a few specials for
you for being a listener the first one
is 20 off pure sport products the most
tested and trusted CBD oil in the world
used by professional athletes all over
the globe the oil is perfect for muscle
and joint pain or even just sleeping at
night and they have a whole heap of
other products available too with the
new wide range of nootropics sold here
right in New Zealand to get your
discount all you need to do is enter the
code waterlad20 at the checkout and you
are good to go I'll leave a link in the
description below so go get it Mike set
also 20 off the Woodland Coffee Bean is
there for you as well for all you coffee
lovers out there Pomeroy's coffee do the
best being on the market and they also
do a special water lead Bean which you
can get your hands on with 20 off by
heading to the Pomeroy's website I'll
leave a link in the description again
and then just head to the checkout and
enter the code lad03 and then your fresh
coffee beans will be delivered direct to
your door anyway let's get to this
episode with this Champion lad anyway
let's get to this episode with the
champion lab
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a ladwell today I'm joined by
one of the most talented players yet to
play on the all black Jersey and after
another standout NPC with North Harbor
the rumors are out at what's next for
this outstanding Talent over the past
seven years we've seen us form
consistently improve while playing for
the likes of waikato North Harbor the
Chiefs and of course the New Zealand
maoris is also a very Savvy investor so
I'm looking forward to hearing this one
he is the great man himself Shaw and
shooter Stevenson welcome mate thanks
for that yeah um don't go investing on
DVD stores uh 2022 or 2021 that's for
sure and uh thanks for having us it's a
pleasure to be here mate uh you're
obviously very popular with the Woodland
fans already after your prank with Jason
Merritt on it the fiesta video Adult DVD
store
um what do you remember about that oh to
be honest like it was quite a funny
story because I actually uh if Michael
Ellie likes to tell me like the whole
story of like Olive truly believe that
like it was obviously just before
training him obviously I was thinking
about training but obviously catching me
off guard you know I've got this whole
investment idea
I was like yeah yeah sweet sweet like um
I just got to get to training but if you
call me after changing a little bit more
time to like talk will be all good but I
mean
someone must have tipped off at allodice
and Ella Dyson tell me you call me up
next thing and send me some emails and I
probably still would have believed it to
this day to be honest but
yeah not as bad as my uh my Cousy uh
felicities one of the old jockeyser
he takes the cake I think but yeah I
mean if they played a little bit longer
if I would have got to that at that
level yeah jonty will never be beat I
don't think right that one was one of
them right but yeah the thing that
cracked me out was when you messaged me
saying oh you did see it would have paid
that 43k if we kept going with it
[Music]
oh it's so good but how have your
Investments um been going since have you
got into any oh no DVD stores that's for
sure but um I thought I bought myself a
water business so um got a water truck
water brand new water truck and uh went
into business with my um parents
delivering water to people on check
order and following swimming pools on
the North Shore right all the way up to
Omaha if you know where that does that
like marker anyways so
um that's why I'm investment I've done
uh that I know
that is uh true and uh yeah we had our
first summer last last year so
um a little bit you know a few teething
problems with a new a new business but
um
yeah obviously looking forward to the
Summer where it's quite seasonal so just
getting the track ready now to get up
there and get some business done so nice
and I said there's a lot better
investment than the yes videos that's
for sure yeah yeah no yeah nice to make
videos or anything like that so we're
good to go
but let's get to the footy mate um
obviously coming off a pretty massive
season with North Harbor
um your form was outstanding how did you
find it yeah it was it was a good good
season in in a way you know um obviously
playing a couple Maori games you know I
had a bit of an injury where I was up
for a few weeks um joined that super
season and managed to get back for the
all the later stages of it but
um yeah I didn't get picked for those
stages so
um to come out and mold the all bikes
for I think you know probably kicked off
that form in terms of um starting you
know um and getting some consistent game
time
um Brady's probably kickstarted their
NPC season for me and I think I was more
excited about coming back home and yeah
like it's a funny one day like when you
come back to NPC you know when you've
been playing it for a while you kind of
come back and you have that confidence
because you've been doing it for so well
you know even if you make a mistake you
can move on and install you know play a
part in the game you know
so I'm also been around for a while now
it was just good to
throw the poop skin around off so you've
got a boy back to layer back uh Jersey
which was nice so um took a bit of
pressure off me and you know our
backline and
um headstyles all over the show and you
know female is doing their job it makes
a lot easier for yourself and
um changes obviously enough to think
about not just you but seven other boys
in the back line so yeah it's good and
uh yeah it was an enjoyable season mate
one thing that really stood out for me
was watching you guys play was how
Reliant like your team relied on your
back three obviously yourself Mark to
Lair and tavita lay all massive carriers
massive involvements in the game was
that was that part of your plan or is
that just what happened naturally
because obviously mum was always looking
for work naturally but was it part of
your plan to get the ball in your guy's
hand as much as possible because I've
never seen a team have a back three so
heavily involved in a game uh to be
honest mate like we didn't like some of
the moves in there in our set piece and
stuff didn't involve us boys there
um I think you know like I said like the
three of us have been around for a while
and you know we've clicked on to like if
we're not involved in the moves and how
else can we impact on the game
throughout Facebook and stuff like that
like you said Mamba just always wants to
get his hands on the ball and you know I
guess he's a bit of like a ninth anoints
uh Ford from a yeah a fourth loose
forward in terms of picking going and
getting around there and uh you know if
we're creating stuff on the other side
we know that savita's probably gonna
score a hedgehog every game
um
you know it's just stuff like that but
no to be honest we don't really talk
about it you know aspects very pretty uh
we're all pretty close though you know
we don't mind having a bit of a joke and
you know like yeah I think we're just
all on the same page
are two world-class players
um like I said you know if everyone's
doing the job it makes a lot easier for
the person next to them and
um who was creating something is always
uh you know next uh one over again
getting the meat pie so yeah it was good
it was it was good to watch and
obviously your form was so good and
they've just named the all black 15 team
um many people surprised not to see your
name in it how did you feel when you
when you saw that side we you must have
been pretty gutted yeah obviously pretty
together not to make that team um you
know
sold out you know had a pretty good
season and I think quite a few other
boys would probably been pretty
disappointed at the moment like that
team either you know probably wasn't
just me that
um felt that way and yeah obviously I
think other you know he'll be lying if
you know I was to say that I wasn't
gutted but yeah that's funny you know
you're not the one that's choosing the
team and I guess you just
yeah I gotta move on and not dwell on it
for too long because probably starts
affecting other people in your life then
you know you're a bit of a sad second
you know these other you know other
things going on in this world that you
know probably more important so yeah
obviously get it but what can you do so
what's the feedback what did what what'd
you hear from them uh to be asking no
feedback no calls and I think so really
um so yeah yeah there was the end of it
really just that thing you named and
then
yeah move on true that that blows my
mind that guys who are surely in the
frame for that selection to not even get
a phone call and
um especially guys around your age you
know that 25 to 30 year olds who you
know have been working away for a while
now um cracking on the door to to not
get a phone call that's that's
surprising to me yeah I mean they've
probably got their reasons why but
um yeah I guess you just don't really
know we we you uh think where you are on
the picking order so but yeah what else
can you do you can't you know like I
said dwelling for too long otherwise uh
you know probably doesn't help uh
help yourself in terms of um being in
the right mental frame yeah mental side
of things so yeah but I guess as a
country we always talk about um how many
guys are leaving our Shores and
especially around that age and sometimes
all it takes from these coaches is
potentially a phone call to say how
close you potentially are or what you
could do to potentially get in there but
obviously you're left in the dark and
um you know potentially searching yeah I
mean yeah obviously everyone loves a bit
of feedback in terms of you know how
they can get better or you know where
they see them or you know what
what they need to do but you know they
obviously just
stick to their ways so
um yeah what else can you do yeah and
obviously your form uh impressed
uh one Guru coach in particular Wayne
Bennett
um rumors are that he's giving you the
call he's he's pretty keen on your
services
how was that conversation yeah obviously
um had a phone call from him and
I mean it was daunting in a way but
um quite exciting I guess and you know
um getting a phone call from him because
um probably not really not many people
do so yeah I'll see it's one of those
things where
um you know it's like everyone you know
you've got to keep the options open see
what happens and I've always wanted to
pay but I've been around before and it
was just like nice to get a phone call
and you know talk about a turkey and
yeah it was good what's that what's the
phone call pre-planned or like how did
how did that all work or just randomly
out of the blue yeah let's be honest
yeah just got a phone call and random
number was it just a random number a
random number you love a random number
phone call
yeah it wasn't a DVD uh phone call but
um yeah it was uh it was a Wayne so that
was good so he's obviously one of the
best coaches uh if not the best coach in
rugby league um that people have seen so
that was cool have you played any League
before no League no League self
obviously like coming through school and
um you know I guess when you get to that
age and especially in New Zealand like
everyone just plays rugby and then if
you you know League Scouts of stuff
coming you know if you want to go down
that that road of uh playing League then
you just play first a thing and then you
know most boys you know go the Dozier
try calculating the league so yeah it's
just always been a rugby for me but you
followed it closely and apparently
you're pretty gun on NRL fantasy and
super coach and things like that yeah
obviously the boys love it they like uh
yeah 24 of us boys at Chase played uh
you know our fantasy this year that's
you um yeah everyone just gets around it
yeah it's just one of those things and I
guess there's so much of it that you
just watch you know it's always on the
TV you know throughout the weekends and
obviously when you're going away for for
rugby you know you've got a lot of
downtime that night so you just
obviously there's a few games on every
night so you just sit down and have a
geese and it's good what position do you
reckon you'd play oh
I'd like to play it either fall back or
steps but
um your Center maybe yeah yeah I mean I
think the position probably suit me so
yeah did Wayne Bennett talk about any of
those like where he saw you or things
like that no you guys just rang me up
for a chat and just you know see what
I've been up to and you know I guess
just asking if you know I had thought
about playing rugby league before and
whatnot so yeah that was about it really
just
got to know me a bit more on yeah I
guess it's
I mean you're talking on the phone you
can't really get that personal
interaction and yeah you know
okay that's a nitty-gritty but that was
a good conversation yeah did it get your
did it get you excited excited about the
potential opportunity to head over there
I mean I remember talking to TJ before
he was potentially off to the roosters
and remember how excited he was around
um the idea of playing in the NRL I mean
geordie's obviously been pretty Keen
together to go as well at some point but
no one's actually done it yet I'll be
pretty Keen to see someone actually do
the leap and make the move and hoping
it's you yeah I guess it's an exciting
um Prospect I think a lot of boys talk
about today yeah it's one of those
things that
um heaps of rugby boys want to go give
it a crank and you know a lot of people
talk about it but never thought yeah um
but yeah it's obviously exciting
opportunity if it does come about but
yeah like I said it's you know everyone
everyone plays the email fantasy
everyone watches it so it's just been
always one of those things you just like
uh you know have a cracker and just see
what it's like but you're currently
contracted with the Chiefs for how long
so when when are you potentially able to
make that switch if if you decided to go
there I got one more year so oh yeah
yeah and one more year worth North
Harbor no I'm not contractable partly
yet so
um
yeah that's just one year of Chase sir
sure
um yeah we'll see what happens so could
make them uh switch for finals footy
potentially but now yes I guess it's all
come about recently so
um you know obviously it's been part of
a world one couple weeks you know with
the Olympic 15 and NPCs finishing last
week for me so um yeah I'm just cruising
at the moment yeah what do you reckon
the hardest thing to adjust would be
switching over to League oh I'm not sure
probably just the wrestling and um all
that kind of you know that physical side
of things you know just
obviously it's a lot more um upper body
based I guess like defense chest on
chest and you know on the ground just
wrestling and slowing down the rock
plane and stuff like that so
probably just there I mean depending
what position I guess you play and I
guess you get if you're on Tech it's
quite structural in a way but it's also
quite open in terms of you know what you
know if you get full back and slipping
around the Rocks like you do probably
during Union around you know nine and
ten and stuff so yeah I guess that's
probably that side of these just
wrestling and stuff but you'd be pretty
excited about the fifth tackle options
putting up your big floater bombs and
things like that you know I think like
most people are especially like even at
rugby training you're playing you know
league is there like before captains run
and yeah you've got props trying to do
float you know floating bombs and stuff
like that so everyone's trying to you
know
get one of those in or try doing like
magical plays which NRL team do you
support at the moment like who who's
your team oh to be honest I don't really
follow a teammate like yeah I guess like
I said like there's that that much leg
on that you kind of just watch
whatever's uh going on or
you know if you're at home and settling
in yeah just watch whatever yeah but
that doesn't mean that's a safe answer
for someone with plenty of clubs coming
circling over the next few weeks
so but yeah like I said I think about
just watches are there it's just one of
those games that people enjoy watching
and I'll see when you get like a storm
goes Panthers you know it's always like
living up to yeah expectations and
everyone you know it's a good game to
watch May exciting times exciting times
ahead for you I'm looking forward to
following it and like like I said I'd be
Keen to see you um do that switch it
would be awesome to see a union player
and jump over but if not mate hopefully
start getting selected in some of these
teams and we can keep you in this game
but anyway mate as always I'm pretty
Keen to hear your journey from the start
like see how you got to where you did
and what your childhood was like so
where'd you grow up I grew up in um so
like about 40 minutes north of Auckland
um the Hibiscus Coast so yeah let's go
guess when you're heading up North like
are you always but your hibiscus Coast
so I've done my primary school years at
the year one six and then went in to
meet it at Northcross intermediate at
the time I think was like the biggest
intermediate in New Zealand like I had
about 1200
um pupils and was just year seven year
eight so
um headed down to the shore and uh I
actually didn't get into Westlake which
was like the school to go to so we say
boys on the shore because I was out of
the zone and all my mates went there but
missed out on that then
we had a family friend that went to uh
Auckland grandma that lived in Golf
Harbor sealed Fury and every day and
then um bus up to to school at Grandma
but applied our zones in their Zone and
then managed to get an interview to
um the hostel there airport in school so
managed to sneak into there and yeah did
my um secondary school year years at um
Auckland Grandma so just kept heading
South I guess I mean obviously even look
at the Chiefs and like Heather but yeah
yeah I love I love my time at all those
three schools you know you know I
couldn't couldn't speak highly enough
for all those schools that I went to so
we always again at school like well yeah
were you A Gifted kid coming through the
age grades oh true I wasn't like gifted
at all like I um you know obviously had
some a little bit about me I guess but
um I wasn't big or I was like well I
think when I had my first year at year
11 at first 15 like I was probably only
like
55 oh maybe not 55 like 60 kgs like
dripping wet like
yeah I was honestly so skinny and at
Grandma like everyone thinks it's a
private school it's a public school
everyone thinks that we do like seven or
eight sessions a week like Hamilton boys
or Saint Kitts at the time but literally
only did like
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday training and
then maybe one gym up there and I did go
to the gym at school like it was just
not for me and probably probably should
because I'm having down there when I
went down to Hamilton like
I do like I signed with an academy
contract and I literally did one month
there
maybe not even there and I started
playing
um for Hamilton all boys in club rugby
and then Chase are like oh now coming so
I literally came with a Chase Monday to
Friday then play Club 40 on Saturday in
my first year in 2015 of school because
I already done like a preseason after my
second form year like literally a couple
weeks before Christmas all right and
honestly I wins the gym my first time
like still still to this day I still get
[ __ ] about it but James low and Brad
Weber like watching me and I was full
Healey who's the blues trainer but was
the cheese train at the time
and I honestly never been in the gym and
I'm not truly here bench pressing a bar
just the bar and honestly like all the
top dogs in there and I'm literally just
pushing a bit I'm just pushing a button
like everyone's just looking over like
what the hell like put this kid died did
not do any gym at school but literally I
was like at that point obviously a year
13 I was like 75 70 cages dripping wet
yeah so I was on those like
thousand calorie shapes like three of
them a day just for the first two or
three years just trying to pile it on
here so
yeah it's a Staybridge you know it
brings the fire remember when you um
came first came into your Devastation
maybe maybe it would have been 40K it
may be 20 kg wasn't that but like yeah
you had 10 cages on the slide and you're
only bench pressing 40 kgs but yeah
so skinny back then oh that's so
probably so probably called me scanning
now yeah so it's all good and what like
was ragley always like your pathway
obviously you look like someone who'd be
talented at a lot of different sports
was there any other sports which you
were good at oh
um I played my future touch back in the
day oh yeah um like that was like my
summer sport I guess and then yeah I
guess it's always been Rugby's uh rugby
for me like
yeah ever since I was occur I just grew
up playing Rigby and obviously when you
get to school you want you want to
travel to other sports like Cricket yeah
what else was there touch Cricket I
guess that you played volleyball like do
all these sports but I guess when you
get to secondary schools you kind of
just have to stick to a couple of sports
you know you either go one one way or
the other in terms of choosing a Sports
Zone
um I was catch a rugby for me and yeah
that was that was just my those two
sports probably intertwined into each
other and
um yeah and then who got you down to who
got you down to waikato on the Chiefs
right and did someone come and approach
you while you're at school yeah so um
actually so I made the secondary school
team for New Zealand and then we had our
first game against Fiji and put it all
apart
and it was about like 40th minute or
just after half time and I'll let you
into score try and as I got tackled I
left
um funny as I was called to try I broke
the collarbone
and um obviously gathered because I can
play out the rest of the tournament and
then I got a phone call uh maybe a week
later and it was um Andrew Strawbridge
and Dave Rooney calling me up asking for
a meeting so I yeah obviously talk at
him they meet me halfway with my mum at
Bombay Hills and yeah I'll see didn't
look back after that and that was the
end of it and healthy that she offers to
stay in Auckland and harbor but I
literally just went on the academy
contract like I had like full pu
contracts uh and other teams but I think
just the fact that they meet me halfway
and you know told me to come down and I
guess it all worked out in a way because
obviously
um so as soon as I got down there maybe
four or five months later got offered a
three-year contract from them so
um yeah those those two got me down
there so
yeah I got no wonder you're um we're
only benching 20 kgs you've just broken
your collarbone oh yeah but probably why
yeah I lost it I was obviously worked in
both ways but you know yeah probably
broke my collar mode because I had
literally just phoned all OverWatch I
was just kidding and how'd you find it
going into
um those environments down there
obviously super young like you said
pretty intimidating in the gym but what
about on the field did you feel
confident you always look like a
confident kid yeah I mean obviously I
saw a joke with this for Friday
Metallica every day where you go oh you
don't [ __ ] Chris on the field so yeah
yeah oh obviously you know that was
probably the thing that was um keeping
me in the game was you know probably my
skill set and stuff like that when I was
young so obviously not a bit stronger
than German what not but um just yeah my
school said and how I played the game
when I was obviously okay that was
obviously
pretty uh
pretty daunting coming to the
environment because
you know they'll find a couple of
championships before that and they've
always been in the finals and stuff like
that you know like my when I was 18 I
think I had one training
literally just before Christmas so 20 so
yeah it would have been 2015 but you
know coming to 2015
um before Christmas
and I did like we did like a backs on
back scrums and
to like a Midfield I think it was like a
two two pullback and stuff like that got
the ball at the back and I just see
someone came from the corner of my eye
and obviously like you know with
defenses you've got split the bodies and
ones on outside
balls grass scattered Sunny ball
straight straight
off slightly yeah that's welcome to
welcome the super agony
uh but yeah that obviously was having
that first year where I actually wasn't
contracted but I was doing like Monday
to Friday obviously um helped a lot
because obviously it wasn't a gym full
time and
um was learning a lot off everyone else
so that was good yeah and I remember the
waikato side back then was a really
young side as well I remember he had
like Anton Leonard Brown's Amy McKenzie
all coming through about the same time
as you Brad Webber around there
potentially Eva as well coming back at
some point to steer the ship but I'm
real good uh young crew where you guys
were just playing some real entertaining
rugby yeah I think I think my debut game
was against the Marcos that that yeah
tough start yeah tough start but uh
scored up debut so I'll take that but uh
yeah obviously we had we'd be at Half
Back Damien at 10 and on the back line
we're like Declan O'Donnell and Don
Collier and
Mr Jacobson big big farmer Tommy fauna
um how many five uh Brian Ellen easy
yeah like we had a good team Jacob's
skiing
um Adam Byron yeah we had a good good
team and was enjoyable and we next have
a good good season that yeah but um got
to the last game and I think we're like
three and six or something like that and
we had a red for the shield challenges
yeah
um we managed to upset the Hawke's Bay
and take the shield off them so we had
it for the summer so that was pretty
cool doing it in your first year and
haven't been successful so yeah that was
it was a guaranteeing to the apartment
because obviously
was sort of starting off on our Journeys
yeah man it's a hard thing to win that
Shield
um but
what's the celebration like I think I
remember Weber um speaking about a
little bit in his podcast but what do
you remember of it obviously young 18
year old
um probably first big experience in a
shield game and shield celebrations how
was it yeah was that the gate was out
the gate I think they even was in the
team that yeah I think his house had a
few celebrations and yeah I think I
think he had his golf cart down there
sometimes so
um I think that got out but they got out
for a few um cruises
um but yeah that was Good Friday
obviously
um first time
off the you know like I said having a
pretty [ __ ] season and then to get their
information on the last game yeah don't
really care if you wanted to you had to
show for someone so that was that was
the next best thing if not probably
better than that yeah right so good and
then talk to me about like your sort of
chiefs like when did you first get your
debut for the chase was that the
following year
yeah so 2016 I had my first first year
and yeah debuted when it first came
against the Crusaders which was cool so
yeah the journey there and yeah
obviously eight or nine years later
yeah so that's good all right crazy yeah
and you're still so young so how do you
find the um step up to Super Rugby did
you feel it way more intense than what
you're playing yeah 100 I was kind of
like we can't have this conversation the
other day with some of the boys you know
like
we talked about like if you're coming
from Club level to NPC it's one of those
things where like if you make a few
mistakes you kind of feel like you know
you're going to get dropped because you
actually haven't played that much in
terms of like you haven't got that
confidence to keep at it I mean it's
like and then you go from NPC to Super
Rugby it's the same thing you know if
you're not an all black
um and you're like it's you know you get
a couple games but you make a couple of
States you kind of you know stay in the
Shell because you're not actually
confident in that level yet
um and then obviously so forth going
into all books but when you're coming
back down the rates in terms of like
your super rugby player and you've been
playing HC for so long
that's probably why boys carve up ABC is
because they've been doing it for a
while and they know like it's their
confidence level in terms of you know if
they make a mistake they can move on and
still have a stay at the game
um for example like all black boys
coming down to Super Rugby level like
you know like just exactly the same
thing in terms of you know if you make a
mistake you know you
you can flush it a lot easier yeah I
think yeah obviously when you're young
and stuff like that like I said you're
obviously pretty nervous in terms of
um being up there and stuff like that so
I guess it's just like getting it right
mental side of things so um we need to
get that opportunity that you'll really
take it with both hands and if you do
make a mistake that
you're mentally got the edge there to
just yeah keep at it and keep moving
forward is that what you sort of put
your form down to over the last sort of
12 months where your game's really gone
to another level oh 100 you know I I
guess it's just like it's like Ibraham
though you get that consistent game time
you know you're going to thrive a lot
more because
you're just you're getting it you you
know you're starting to put things in
place and
you know if I say you know you're a
confidence player but I feel like
everyone's a confidence player like you
can't you can't get that confidence if
you're not playing you know regular
footy and you know if you're coming in
and out it's hard to get that that
confidence you know because you're
probably scared of making a mistake you
know or you know [ __ ] am I going to be
in the team next week and I haven't even
paid it you know what I mean so
um I think a lot of boys feel that way
but persons don't really speak about it
and that in that in that context yeah
100 and even like at the chase at the
moment like you've been there what seven
eight years now and even you guys are
still rotating your outside backs a fair
but hey like you don't get real
consistency on your week to week team
yeah I guess we've got quality players
you know but um yeah I guess it's just
that consistency I guess and you know
everyone getting their turn and you know
like I said like it's a tough one Acres
there's so many quality players but
getting that regular game time was
obviously pretty hard to come by yeah
mate it's interesting yeah but so why
the move to Harbor obviously you were
doing well with waikato and enjoying it
why the move back up north oh this is
home for me like obviously I didn't want
to leave but
I think we can you know you know even
harder can be almost like even back then
they probably went in the best
um and the best their hands in terms of
you know like they probably weren't
playing the best footy and um I think
for my growth as a player and especially
meeting you know with Dave Brennan
Andrews
taking Academy contract over signing a
you know a pu contract which is like a
you know obviously a marketing cap
contract straight away
um which is beneficial for my Rugby and
I guess yeah it's worked out for me in
terms of you know
fighting because obviously had Academy
contract and then still making my thing
cut down that year you know I was on
Academy contract but I had a good Club
season and then was lucky enough to be
picked on the miter 10 Cup squad so yeah
I guess coming back to Harbor was always
home so I was pretty gutted that I had
to leave those boys but I I guess I
always wanted to come back home you know
it's like yourself you know you always
want to you always want to play for your
home problems that's who you grew up
watching and it was just always home for
me and um Family up here and having fun
of a split six months in Auckland six
months in Hamilton was a bit but better
option than spending 12 months in
Hamilton not gonna lie so
but yeah yeah and how did you find the
difference up there like what was the
what's the cultural differences between
North Harbor and waikato oh to be honest
I think like Most Wanted Cup teams
probably have all good cultures you know
like it's I guess that's that's what you
know the players want it to be like you
know they've got the coaches there but
you got players coming from Club rugby
you've got players coming from Super
Rugby you've got players sometimes
coming down from the All Blacks and I
guess having like those core players
have been there for you know three or
four years to get their culture humming
you know it's to be honest I think
Harbor's got one of the best cultures
I've you know
obviously going to be quite biased but
like you speak to everyone that comes in
they love their experience there and
yeah that's what we try to do you know
we have a bit of fun off the field but
um
also
um enjoy it on the field as well yeah
mate not many people complain about
their
um NPC culture a like no yeah be
interesting to hear mumba's opinion on
how Tasman Compared to North Harbor but
um yeah it sounds like you guys have a
pretty cool culture up there as well so
and one thing that's been um sort of
part of your career to date as well as
the New Zealand Maori side you've been
in and around that few times
um have you found those experiences yeah
I I love playing film audio books like
um it's one of the best or however long
you're in there like time of your lives
in terms of just immersing yourself with
like the culture and you know the boys
are unreal to play with you learn so
much about you know your heritage and
just the whole week from start to finish
is just you know it's just unreal like I
mean until you're actually in there like
you you know it's it's hard to put it
all into words but yeah it's just it's
just a great team to be part of and
obviously there's so much Rich history
there
um you know from back in the early 1900s
to to now and you know obviously people
hear about the jerseys and they feel
like looking detail to the jerseys and
stuff like that there's just so much so
much history behind it and why it's like
that so yes it's always it's always an
honor when you get get mainly the team
because um you just know it's going to
be a a very you know fun week but also
you know putting Maori moldy rugby back
on the map and that's what you're trying
to do and you you know try to you know
Nathan so you can actually play against
decent opposition to further you know
the oldie rugby and you know keep
putting it on the map yeah and I I guess
the moment where you really uh put your
name on the international scene I guess
was uh the test Series against Ireland
where had a standout series and like you
say getting to play against quality
opposition and putting Maori rugby on on
the map again but you'll form personally
uh you must have been happy with how
that um
um yeah obviously I I done my HCL like a
grade 2 so
yeah I was available for last week
against a Rigby and um didn't get picked
but you know to play that first game
back after about eight or nine weeks off
against the island a little Island at
fmg stadium and I guess it was just one
of those things where like like I said
like I've been there for a while now
where yeah I hadn't played in a while
but I think I was just so excited
um it was a different challenge of
playing against Ireland yeah it was just
one of those games where you get a few
touches on the ball and you feel good
about yourself and you get a couple more
and then you know yeah you'll got some
space in front of you and it was just it
was just a main game to play and
obviously nothing like playing at fmg
Stadium yeah probably the best film in
New Zealand
this is it oh that's a bit cool
that's not I mean yeah
I think yeah most people can uh agree on
that yeah no it does always have a
really good service for sure uh and
another team that you've played for the
barbarians um when did you play for them
because I do always love a good
Barbarian story yeah well um thanks to
Brent Gatlin um it was actually Warren
gatlin's last game against uh Wales
um so Brandon Brennan the good word he
got uh Duffy Brent Hall and myself and
Bryn was meant to bring Gatlin was meant
to play but he'd done his um his foot um
during Super Rugby so he's out for a
while but yeah he managed to get on the
big burn fly to Wales and have a one-off
game against Wales at Cardiff which was
I'm obviously never played in Cardiff
but you know obviously being one getting
his last game uh 60 000 uh well fans
just you know especially singing there
national anthem and
um yeah it was Unreal it was Unreal
experienced to be part of and obviously
when you're
testing out like Monday to Monday to
Thursday or something like that it's
yeah it was uh a few Hunger Games as a
game of touch and oh it was like yeah
sweet just rock up and yeah get some
curtain
throw the baller out for touch and yeah
man it's crazy yeah it's crazy like the
prep and like were you nervous going
into the game obviously playing in front
of 60 000 you're probably still slightly
hung over you've just been on the purse
you don't really know the game plan were
you nervous going out onto the field but
thinking like should I haven't prepared
very well for this one yeah yeah that
was that I wasn't nervous about the game
I was more nervous because I hadn't done
any prep beforehand been like
that was like so obviously we finished
for Harbor so we had like three or four
weeks off and also you do like a little
bit of training but also you and I'm
kind of the mood where you're like you
know I'm also it's my off season now but
yeah
um yeah and you're on the bus for like a
whole week and then you have to go play
so that was probably the most
nerve-wracking thing because obviously
so what you saw were gonna you know play
it again for you it's not a game of
touching you know you're actually
playing against the international side
too yeah
um probably had all these Stars playing
as well don't have all this stuff how'd
you go no we just lost that right we
lost by like seven or ten or something
like that like it was a close game but
um it was the end of also most of the
boys have already been on like played
two games before that so they probably
had like a three-week out like hangover
already so
um we had to bring it by the Frozen
energy when we got there because we were
The Late Late covers and yeah but still
good fun you know obviously guys
warranties coming out with you is like a
obviously the pope there you know like
she's the he's the big dog dude you know
he's just kidding
yeah don't worry about the players it's
all about Lauren Gatlin when you're out
you know fixtures and autographs and
stuff like that yeah it was just like
real it's crazy it blows my mind that a
team can prepare like that and still
like run an international team who's
been training and preparing for games
like this for like months and you know
doing their structures and all this and
still you know have a competitive game
um against a team that's just been
pissing up and not really preparing for
it yeah boys up boys but up for it
obviously didn't get the dub but um I
guess when you uh put your boots on and
switch on it's all good that's it that's
it and that's funny I guess but uh
obviously your plans going forward um
we've sort of spoken about that a little
bit already it sounds like you're off to
the NRL in 2024 but
what what are your plans
yeah now what are your plans have you
thought much further ahead than the
Chiefs obviously you've got NRL circling
what are the other options here stay
with the Chiefs oh to be honest about
I'm just keeping my options open at the
moment I know like just keep leaving
before they do the talking and obviously
just you know see what pops up and you
know what my agent can come up with yeah
but yeah the moment just keep them
options open whatever happens happens
and it's one of those you know cliche
points what yeah whatever comes to you
or whatever you know you just follow
your heart yeah it'll be the right
option does the Japan Market interest
you or um Europe playing rugby in Europe
does any of those ones sort of interest
you oh obviously both of them interested
it's like one of those things if you do
leave New Zealand is it yeah you saw you
know accomplishing to make the money
side of things you know like obviously
Japan aren't real money there but
or do you go you know over the French
top 40 and you still get that challenge
you know you still get that a constant
of you know I'm still trying to you know
still be you know obviously Japan's
competitive but yeah you know it's
challenging competitive I mean a French
one as well you know so
um and then make a decision off that I
guess right exciting right love to be in
your shoes you're in a good position
with the form you're in I've I'm sure
plenty of uh clubs will be circling but
uh you sort of mentioned a little bit
before around um your water truck so
plans for after footy if you've got much
in plan
um life post footy you're gonna looking
to take this water business globally
yeah I don't know about globally but uh
I think you know you obviously get into
housing and you know my own house and
stuff like that but um
yeah I guess business is a different
different base than I think you might
take a lot out of um being in a team
environment you know with a footy team
being in the professional moment we're
pretty fortunate and lucky to always
have people come in and have um you know
PD talks
um about you know what we want to do and
all people coming in who've been in that
area before and giving you some tips and
stuff like that so
I always you know even at school like my
favorite topic to study and all my
favorite subject was business studies so
um yeah I guess you learn a lot from
that as well in terms of
what you're doing rugby and transfer
some of that to business and then what
you learn in business and you transfer
that into the rugby you know like it's
yeah actually there's quite a few um
similarities so yeah I mean hopefully uh
I have my own my own business and oh
yeah I've got that now but
um you never know what's going to happen
uh 10 years down the track or
um yeah so but yeah at the moment the
water truck one truck businesses
it's all good you know just keeping
taking over there's certainly assessing
that you've jumped into it so early
while you're still playing like you'll
be learning so much from what you're
doing at the moment and just like even
if it doesn't go that well
um what you would have learned while
you're doing it when you get to the end
of your footy career mate you would have
learned so much and you'll be in such a
good position to start your own business
and whatever you want but I'm sure the
water truck is going to go humming
because everyone needs some water in
their life yeah and you see anyone is
water so um yeah we'll see how that goes
but yeah like like you said like if it
doesn't work it doesn't work but yeah
you can learn a lot from it and
um be better off you know but hopefully
I don't get to that that stage I can
give it up and running and then that's
why I don't want to build anymore I can
sell it off and yeah I have to not have
to crash and burn but uh yeah we'll see
where that goes how it goes bro but yeah
at the moment second second season then
so try to get a handling and have a good
summer love it mate as always I've gone
to the Instagram for some questions and
make plenty of come through obviously
ninety percent of them were around
um the NRL switch and the Dolphins and
all that so and we've pretty much
covered all of that also heaps of them
were filthy that you hadn't made the ABS
15 so we've covered that as well but
we'll fly through the rest of them
um how'd you get the nickname shooter
this must be a good yarn uh a little bit
of yeah but I was just watching um Happy
Gilmore before our first ever game for
waikato it was uh oscillating with
um Damien and Anton and yeah well
literally just watching it the night
before and it was just yeah I guess
we'll just make it a bit of an inside
joke and
um
yeah obviously manage the score on debut
the night the the night after and
um shared in the game and you know
obviously it was one of the main
characters in that team and
um I guess the only way to act out like
shouldn't be given was to shoot the
camera so
that's how it's going bad and it's stuck
um since then so
mate it has stuck everyone calls you
shooter no way just from that that's
that's good stuff
okay next one best Damian and Anton
flatting story
oh
I don't know about the best story but
there's been there was one like story
like stalking story like
yeah it was like I don't know who they
were but they're probably stalking it um
no like no [ __ ] like they'll follow us
to like the new world like they would
park outside our house and we would jump
in the car go like
go to like the new world and like follow
us from behind and like they probably
did it for about a week or two sure and
once like they like followed us to New
World and then we're like [ __ ] we like
we clicked onto it is like we've got a
bit of stalkers in there like we're
parked up and then like we're like go
inside and then we'll walk back out and
like maybe like they'll cut down the
road like 50 to 100 meters
oh [ __ ] this is weird like they didn't
do anything but they're like what's
going on here like it was out the gate
and then one time well it might have
been like Christmas time and
they followed me all the way up to
Rainbow's End
from your house to Rainbow's End I was
out the gate it was crazy it was crazy
like and so then I'll say you're
thinking you're like Need for Speed and
you're like going weaving in between
traffic okay what's going on here but I
didn't like this in this game too much
so
um yeah that was probably one of them
like that was yeah that was probably one
of the stories that was crazy all right
well they're just weaving in and out of
traffic behind you well yeah like I lost
them like I lost them but like yeah they
followed me and I was like because
obviously you knew what the car looked
like because it had been you know
outside your house for a couple of weeks
yeah yeah I don't know oh geez who were
they like what sort of age or two tracks
like two tracks like true probably like
probably still at school or something
like that but it was out there okay true
just fellas shooter and um
so that was like yeah that was a crazy
story I was yeah jeez it is it is crazy
that's good stuff okay next one this one
came in probably
um almost as much as your NRL stuff um
why did it take you so long to pay the
Lawns The Lawns
well I'm actually not living in Hamilton
so they actually so getting ready comes
out and cuts my lawn so he'll see if
they can achieve so oh yeah
um yeah probably because he earns too
much money
okay makes fun biggest snatch you've
ever kicked training or game obviously
that big one in the uh NPC from 60 that
was massive yeah that's probably my
biggest because I had a lot of um people
in my back about me just being a trading
cooker it was actually quite funny
because the week before we went up for a
few beers and obviously Maddie games
places yeah
because I said to him I actually
messaged him after I clicked that 60
meters but he said that night that if I
could anything over 50 meters that he
would post on the story saying that Sean
Stevenson's got a bigger boot than muddy
pants so yeah when I messaged him after
the game I sent him the video and I said
I just sent him the video and I didn't
say anything and then he tried to call
me and he was in Queenstown I think he
was on the plus seven yeah
um break up but yeah so yeah probably I
had to get a lot of people on my back
because they are just going Sean you're
just a training ticket you're trying
you're training to wear a lot I've had
them on kittens run from like 60s out
and stuff like that but
had a few opportunities this year and
their first game was opened the most and
then yeah obviously to get that one
against Auckland was um the monkey off
the back which was there quite nice yeah
nice jacket well 60 meters were you
confident as soon as you hit it uh I was
confident because it was going straight
and like yeah it's always nice when you
know like when it comes off the boat but
obviously just went over but um yeah I
kind of like turned around and I was
like yeah I've had that nicely and then
I had to like kind of like take a look
again just like sorry because I wasn't
sure if I had the legs
next question okay this one's a weird
one but is it true you gave a random guy
at Hidden Valley your shorts because his
were lost and you just walked around all
night and your jocks what a lap
well I don't think I I don't think I did
but then again
yeah you probably you're probably
intoxicated
but unless we maybe stock shorts because
he was getting chased by security or
something and I was a swinger you know a
good thing to swap short so to get
kicked out yeah
love it yeah okay two more questions
this one came in a couple of times would
you play for the Warriors obviously a
lot of Warrior fans out there oh never
say never if they offered
well they'll be listening so um they'll
be probably kind of calling I worked for
Geordie who knows mate next week once
this is released they're coming okay
last question best piece of advice you
have for a woodland listener love
finishing with
some advice
I'll probably go touch on that point
actually about the confidence that yeah
really like
um it's probably just
sticking at it like you know once you've
once it's like muscle memory you know
and something that you actually truly
believe that you're good enough to be
there it's probably just sticking at it
like
you know like there's a lot of players
that probably are good enough to be
there but it's that mental side of
things so there's probably not much
separating other boys in the same
position but some of the boys might just
have a better mental
um capacity so
probably just sticking out and just keep
trying and believing in yourself that
you are good enough to be there
100 oh you the further you go away the
more you notice is how little difference
there is like physically and all that
between players it is that mental
difference and being able to stay in the
moment um you know all those things you
talk about
that's the game that's the difference
between the good players and the greats
yeah 100 right love that advice from you
what a way to finish one of the great
podcasts
um awesome to catch up thanks for
jumping on I know you're
um everyone's wanting to talk to you at
the moment with the rumors circling but
I appreciate you giving up your time and
jumping on and really excited to see
what's next for you um like I said I'm
pretty Keen to see you on the NRL but
also um it'd be great to have you stay
here and Rugby Union but really
appreciate you coming on mate no no
awesome thanks for having me obviously
uh
obviously what a ladders got me before
with a bit with a joke so it's obviously
nice to just have a normal chat talk
about DVD stores
no appreciate appreciate you doing here
I'll see a good thing in the Rugby World
of all these podcasts so that's cool
appreciate it brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]